hey guys welcome to and asked easy I'm
Justine this is channel and that's Bri
over there the only way that I can you
bring in to be in a video is I have a
separate camera set up in filming the
couch cam so I asked you guys on Twitter
to ask us some questions and we're going
to answer and bring in it's still over
there on the couch okay well the TV will
be back on just hold on we have a couple
of questions do you and your sisters
fight a lot no not usually except we
turn the TV off and I try to make free
and film video or when we play college
she doesn't like it
yeah speaking of call duty Bram what do
you think about us playing xbox
now the Briana does the pharmacist does
she give you discounts on medication no
what she did tank I don't take any
medication she did take our blood
pressure so a mouthful just listen oh
whatever happened to my bamboo plant
Billy he died was their favorite
Christmas song best time of the year do
all three of you play call of duty
just the James this is our call of duty
gaming setup Roku and I came over to
visit my family
puzzle station right there so root beer
here's mine we got our headsets cousin
game capture and I didn't capture hardly
any games while I was here
pretty sweet huh I like it breeze like
it bless you mommy mommy has a sneezes
next question why does it bring big more
videos I'm sorry what don't like
I'm sorry what doesn't punch you
okay ask you why shouldn't you where did
you get your fantastic iphone keys um I
got my iPhone case at the Verizon store
Jenna why don't you get your I reminded
the rice answer before you I mean was Oh
Fred saw Frank Oz in a nightie wants to
know if you would ever team up with brie
to annoy Jenna I would probably punch
you brutally I love that would you want
to team up
I scared though really though really
don't really really don't they call me
Oh actually somebody says black ops
modern warfare 3 or black ops 2
I'm down with black ops 2 I like like
I'm sound like one four three those
never even know we'll be traveling over
Christmas break
yes I'll be back here yeah where are you
you really hate this Xbox or Wii or Wii
U
well I don't know how the Wii U is
because FedEx decided not to deliver it
and they don't deliver things on
Thanksgiving and I'm leaving tomorrow so
I know okay this is to you guys be
honest how much of a terrible influence
is Justine been oh that's for the fine
brothers braces hi
Greece's hi Brianna hi ass guys did you
make a video interviewing Ariana
when using a Sharpie hello event in New
York we did are you going go get candy
free where are you going
what are you going well that's it this
episode of the easy questions thank you
guys so much for your question thought
they were it easy answer that's my show
easy easy I don't even remember what
mine was we didn't even answer any
questions well Brienne was being a
little sour poo anyway we had great
Thanksgiving lots of baby food let me
know what she was thankful for I think
over Jenna and Brianna for my family and
my fans in for the 10 days off from
school and for Xbox because your payment
Sunday career those pants I got this
alright one more special I will see you
guys when I see you
yeah me too only guys can see me on my
channel it's me Johnny eme what I was
just saying oh you guys can check out
our channel it's me Johnny what's
Brienne's channel minutes a brave
minutes of meanie
how about minutes of cranky it's a
cranky you guys can see minutes of
cranky on my sassy Sunday episodes every
Sunday gaming turkey is in the oven is
turkey in the oven mommy
I show them our Milo to open this look
at that Turkey